you literally [__] said we're calling
the episode Chad [__] a cheeseburger
and I turned it dirty yeah because
you're [__] you're doing like a macho
man like he's having sex that's not cool
oh my God now I've somehow disrupted the
sanctity of Macho Man sometimes you
gotta make it with you're gonna make a
cheeseburger then you're gonna [__] it
you gotta be careful you wanna grow your
own beef so you know what's in there you
don't just go to AM PM yeah and [__] a
cheeseburger number one reason for that
is those microwaves get to Center those
things molt not or a bean and cheese
burrito which might even be the size of
your penis if you slide that in there
you'll get second degree burns yeah from
that from that cheese it's not even real
cheese it's plastic and they're feeding
it to babies yeah snap into a bean and
cheese burrito with your penis yeah